well now in just a week from now the
world's most important conference on
international security starts in the
German city of Munich and I am pleased
to be able to welcome now the head of
the Munich Security Conference and
former German ambassador to the United
States Wolfgang ich and go mr. Ishimura
thank you so much for joining us this
morning
it's a pleasure good morning now I'd
like to begin with one of the big
stories today as we've heard France set
to oppose Germany on Nord Stream McCrone
also canceling his joint appearance at
this year's Munich Security Conference
how worried are you that cracks are
forming in the relationship between
France and Germany right now well let's
let's keep the facts straight
we were planning I had invited president
Michel and Chancellor Merkel to appear
together actually I tried that already a
year ago a year ago it didn't work
because there was a German problem
Chancellor Merkel didn't have a
government fully formed last February so
this plan fell through at the time I was
hoping very much that this year we could
go forward and a week ago actually a
week ago not yesterday the jelly's they
told us that president Markov was not
going to be able to come as planned and
the reasons that were given to us had to
do with the need of the president of
France to entertain his national
dialogue and to worry about domestic
issues rather than go abroad for this
particular conference so for us this is
unfortunate but not a big tragedy but
but I mean what do you think it says
though about the state of affairs here
in Europe because I mean you had
previously welcomed to this as a way of
showing that Europe is not falling apart
you highlighted the domestic issues
both countries were you wrong well no I
mean look France even if President Marco
isn't going to speak himself in Munich
we will have plenty of other senior
representatives of the French government
in Munich to explain French positions
there will be a huge American delegation
congressional delegation they will be
half-a-dozen German ministers etc etc so
I think the purpose which I which is
important to me
the purpose to demonstrate in Munich
that the European Union is alive and
kicking that purpose can still be
maintained we will have plenty of
European speakers from Germany from
France from a number of other important
European countries including the current
Romanian presidency etc etc etc so my
for me it's very important that we
demonstrate especially to the
anglo-saxon community that the
impression that may be created elsewhere
that because of brexit the European
integration project is about to crumble
that that's wrong
actually popular support for the
European Union in most countries is up
not that but if we drill down a little
bit deeper into the security situation
here in Europe I mean there's been much
talk about a common European defence
especially with the u.s. calling the
NATO alliance into question recently
what is your take on current efforts
because I mean Europe doesn't seem to be
in too big of a rush to make any
dramatic moves is it missing an
opportunity well if you ask me
personally I think we could do even a
lot more than what is currently being
done to strengthen you know indigenous
European military capabilities
especially in the conventional area but
let's also be fair there are important
initiatives take for example we
you you raised the franco-german
relationship there is now on the drawing
board a new franco-german fighting
fighter aircraft which has just been
agreed that is a very very important you
know symbolic but also substantial and
new initiatives in the direction of
strengthening and pooling European
military capabilities but I but I would
be the first to agree we could even do a
lot more especially we in Germany where
the defense effort is not I think what
it should be
how about also when it comes to the
defense of multilateralism just just
generally speaking you know that
rules-based order that was established
in the wake of World War two
institutions like the UN the WTO for
example I mean it's come under attack by
populism politics around the world
miracle speaking recently about the
importance of preserving it it's how do
you see the prospect for making
meaningful changes to address current
challenges and really supporting that
World Order what's your take well I
think I think this is a key challenge
for the entire European Union if there
is one important bloc in the world that
relies on a free and and and open and
rules-based international order it is
surely the European Union and I think
it's is one of the main tasks for all of
us in the indie you to try to put
together as has been said a kind of an
alliance of multilateral lists around
the world we're not alone there is kind
of that there is Australia there is a
good number of other important countries
out there that have that share our
interest in a global
trade system that share our interests in
strong international institutions that
share our interests in a rules-based
international system so I think we need
to work on that we need to create
partnerships and alliances but the EU I
believe has the calling and and and has
the power actually we represent 500
million people we are the strongest
trading and economic bloc in the world
if you if one looks at current data we
have a lot of economic and soft power
also and that's where we should apply it
building multilateralism rebuilding
multilateralism in a world that's
fraying in the margins and given that
ambassador Asian car just briefly before
we go because we know that you know you
will have high-ranking representatives
there of course at the Munich Security
Conference including from the big three
military powers the US Russia China
which we have really seen redefining
their roles very much in the world
recently what is your key message to
them well I think that it would be a
major disaster for the global future if
we if we really allow a situation
between the big powers to develop that
would look like you know classic great
power rivalry zero-sum games I think we
have we have enough in common between
even Russia and the United States
between Europe and China and everybody
else to to try to work together to put
cooperation to put integration above the
kind of rivalry which seems to be the
motto of 2019 and we will need to talk
about that next weekend in Munich we'll
have some pretty tough hard talk I hope
in order to clarify what the
priorities of responsible leadership
need to be 2019 and we very much look
forward to seeing how those talks
progress we want to thank you very much
Wolfgang issuing your head of the Munich
Security Conference and former German
ambassador to the United States
we very much appreciate it thank you
very much